foreign ever try to pull sexy times on
you and then you just didn't even see it
because she didn't spell it out yes
she's very subtle I think most chicks
are which is yeah she was like I put my
I put my hand on your shoulder and I was
like what dude she was like you're down
to clown that's what she says that's the
chick's problem too why do they wait
till the next day yeah why don't wait
till the next day grab my face in my
head maybe this is a trauma my wife is
never down to clown okay but that's not
true maybe that's a good clowning
frequency what's a good clown of
frequency what are you guys at come
Monday Wednesday Friday once a quarter
yeah once a fiscal quarter once a week
on average well that's pretty good right
yeah maybe but I'd like to get those
numbers up how often do you guys I would
say throwing it down once every two
weeks maybe once a month even do you
send her like a Google calendar invite
you're like hey dude you didn't RSVP you
could always match it up with their
ovulation schedule like they're super
horny like yeah bro you know when
they're ovulating yeah you keep track of
your girl's cycle
no but comment below if you guys